if your readers can't focus on your
writing it's not their fault it's yours
many readers complain that they're too
distracted to read and even when they do
they don't remember anything it's in one
eye and out the other sure you can blame
Tik Tok scrolling lowering IQs or why
not Carol Basin down in Florida but the
best writers know that good writing is
no accident it's the result of careful
design luckily designing writing that
sticks in your reader's brain is
surprisingly simple when you understand
reader psychology so in this video we're
going to look inside your reader's brain
to learn four writing hacks for memory
and attention you can use these hacks to
design user-friendly writing that your
readers will find irresistible and
Unforgettable as an English Professor I
work with a lot of scientists and
engineers and whenever they ask me how
can I improve my writing my answer
usually surprises them I say you already
learned everything you need to be a
great writer in your computer science
class think about it writing is just
like coding you start with an idea and
your goal is to transfer that idea into
the mind of your reader or the computer
good code runs efficiently the machine
performs exactly as the programmer
intends but bad code it misfires it
causes errors ambiguity and confusion
amateur programmers might rely on
memorized scripts or Ai No code tools
but great programmers understand how the
computer processes information that
understanding of the machine
architecture lets them write code that
runs smoothly and effectively and
writing works the same way if you want
to write well you need to abandon
surface level tricks and study these
four features of your reader mind so
that you can shape your writing to fit
so the first step to brain optimize
writing is to understand that readers
have a pretty tough job they're managing
two levels of reading at the same time
which is kind of like skiing if the skis
start pulling in different directions
then your reader is in trouble but but
expert writers know how to keep them in
line so that readers have a smooth ride
so what are those two skis well it works
like this as everyone knows we can build
a ton of different sentences using the
same pieces so these ones right here are
adapted from a passage in Steven
pinker's book The Language Instinct even
though the information is exactly the
same each sentence tells a different
story why is that here's why since we
read from left to right readers perceive
the thing that they read first to be the
star of the show let's call it the topic
it's the thing that the sentence tells a
story about and understanding what the
sentence is about that's the first ski
but while readers are busy figuring out
what the sentence is all about they're
also trying to manage a second ski and
when you read this passage you'll
understand what happens when that second
ski starts to pull away from the first
one now just a warning this is going to
seem pretty difficult to read but that's
exactly the point and don't worry about
it because we're going to fix it next
language is not a cultural artifact that
we learn the way we learn to tell time
or how the federal government works
instead the biological makeup of our
brains is comprised of language among
other distinct pieces children develop
language spontaneously without conscious
effort or formal instruction you don't
have to be aware of its underlying logic
to deploy it every individual possesses
the same language qualitatively and the
more General abilities to process
information or behave intelligently are
themselves distinct from language pH now
I don't know about you but personally I
found that passage pretty difficult to
follow and it's interesting to
understand what made it so difficult to
understand because while you were busy
reading that passage your brain was
managing the first ski which is what's
this sentence all about that is what's
the topic and when you look at each
sentence individually it's pretty easy
to understand what they're all about but
when you zoom out it becomes harder to
answer the second question and that is
what's this passage about is the passage
about language or biology or children
you everyone General abilities we can't
tell so the problem with this passage is
that the topics are all over the place
each sentence is telling a different
story so the reader wants to know how do
they all hang together what are they
doing together kind of like an
impressionist painting writing is
interpreted at different levels of
resolution so it's not enough to just
focus on the sentence level readers also
want to know the meaning of that larger
passage and that's the second ski
whether it's a paragraph a section a
chapter or a book the larger unit of
writing sets the context for how any
individual sentence is going to be
interpreted so the reader needs to
clearly see how each sentence relates to
its larger context that's why sentence
level grammar advice isn't enough if you
want to help your readers keep track of
how these sentences fit into the larger
pattern then you need to zoom out and
follow these three steps first choose
the topics of your sentences carefully
and try to make them the subject of your
sentence so since this passage is about
language let's reorganize the sentences
so that they all share a common topic
second try to make sure that the topics
are short concrete and familiar readers
can't really picture abstract topics
such as the more General abilities to
process information or behave
intelligently so try to make sure that
the topics are easy for the readers to
grasp and visualize because clear
writing is visual it activates the
Mind's Eye third don't vary the topics
just for the sake of variety yes many
writing teachers will tell you to avoid
repetition but they're only looking at
the sentence level repeating the topic
can help the reader see what the larger
passage is about globally so pulling all
that advice together to fix that first
passage we would get something more like
this language is not a cultural artifact
that we learn the way we learn to tell
time or how the federal government works
instead it is a distinct piece of the
biological makeup of our brains language
is a complex specialized skill which
develops in the child spontaneously
without conscious effort or formal
instruction language is deployed without
awareness of its underlying logic
language is qualitatively the same in
every individual and it is distinct from
more General abilities to process
information or behave intelligently
trigger warning this next brain
optimized writing trick I'm going to
show you is pretty controversial at
least according to the rule-based
writing feachers but when you stop
worrying about writing rules and focus
instead on writing tools then you'll be
able to write Pros that flows like water
I'm a poet and I didn't know it
microphone check one two we all know
that feeling of flow when you get so
wrapped up in reading something that you
completely lose track of time and forget
everything else around you it's the
Hallmark of the world's best writing but
that's only a description of flow we
writers want to know why it happens and
more importantly how can we design
writing that gives our readers that
experience of flow speaking of flow here
are two sentences from its leading
researcher Mikel chick sent Mii guess
that's how you pronounce his name chick
sent me high now these are two different
versions of the same sentence and you're
going to see why in a second but the
sentences are each person must prepare
for the condition of Happiness cultivate
it and defend it privately happiness in
fact is a condition that must be
prepared for cultivated and defended
privately by each person the question is
which of these sentences makes the
following passage flow better happiness
is not something that happens it is not
the result of good fortune or random
chance it is not something that money
can buy or power command it does not
depend on outside events but rather on
how we interpret them one of those
sentences is the missing piece of the
puzzle so choose the right one to make
this passage flow people who learn to
control inner experience will be able to
determine the quality of their lives
which is as close as any of us can come
to being happy now if you're a
grimian then you've probably already
spotted that the difference between
these two sentences is the voice 2 a is
in the active voice and to B is in the
passive voice and the passive voice is
forbidden by rules-based writing
teachers including Strunk and white but
you don't need to be a grammar nerd in
order to see that the second sentence
just seems to make the passage flow
better why is that well if you ask me I
think the passive voice works so well
here for two reasons first since the
topic of every sentence that came before
it is happiness it makes sense to
continue that pattern but more
importantly notice how the last three
words of to be introduce a new important
character by each person and notice how
that character appears in the topic of
the next sentence now if we went with
the rules based writing teachers and
avoided the passive voice in favor of
the active voice then then these links
would be completely reversed so no
matter what the rules based writing
teachers say the passive voice in this
sentence just works better because the
first few words link back to what we
just read and the last few words link
forward to the beginning of the next
sentence and that's the key to writing
that flows it's for the sentence to act
like runners in a relay race one picks
up where the other one left off that
means following the old to new framework
old information at the beginning of the
sentence new unanticipated information
at the end of the sentence now do you
ever wonder why you can recognize the
face of somebody who you met years ago
even though you forgot their name like 5
minutes after you just met I always
thought I was just bad with names but it
turns out that there's a really good
psychological reason for this that has
to do with the way that our brains
record memories and when writers
understand this they can hijack that
part of the brain to make their writing
more Vivid and memorable but instead of
just telling you about the nature of
memory I'm about to show you with three
short sentences I mean after all it's
show don't tell am I right your job is
simple focus on each sentence for about
7 seconds and just try to remember the
idea remember the capital of
Indonesia remember the first line of Hey
Jude remember the Mona Lisa
now did you notice anything change as we
moved from one sentence to the other
just to be sure let's try three more
again just focus on the sentence and try
to remember remember the house where you
spent most of your
childhood remember the definition of
truth remember the definition of
watermelon if every sentence felt a
little bit different it's because each
one was asking you to perform different
kinds of mental activities remembering
the capital of Indonesia is pretty
straightforward it's just a quick
factual recall that is unless you
actually live in Jakarta in which case
it probably felt more concrete and
personal but when you were remembering
Hey Jude you weren't thinking of a fact
you probably heard the melody in your
head Paul McCartney's voice and the
piano chords almost like you were
playing the song in your mind
remembering the Mona Lisa well there's a
pretty good chance that you pictured
that famous half smile on her face it's
like your brain is pulling up an image
from some mental gallery and remembering
your childhood home suddenly you're not
just remembering a fact or an image
instead it's more like the smell of
dinner in the kitchen the sound of the
floor is creaking in the layout of the
rooms you might feel like you're
actually walking through that home again
in your mind remember remembering the
definition of Truth is not as simple as
recalling a city name or a painting you
know what truth means but you might not
have a neat readymade definition so you
probably have to pause and think it
through and come up with a definition
that feels right in the moment
watermelon is another interesting one
just hearing the word might make you
picture its red fruit the taste of its
sweetness or a memory of a time when you
ate it then if I asked you to give a
definition of it you'd have to shift
gears going from those sensory memories
to trying to put it into words the point
here is that remembering is not just one
thing as this experiment shows memory is
a whole range of mental activities each
one calling up different parts of our
own inner world that's why it's easier
to remember faces than it is names and
it's also why you should try to make
sure that your writing gives the reader
more than just information we don't
remember words we remember images human
actions and sensory information the
visual part of our brain is way older
than the part that evolved for language
so here are three simple steps that you
can use to make sure that your writing
is Visual and memorable choose concrete
language and examples don't say I was in
Jakarta describe the sights The Sounds
the smells and the feelings that readers
can associate with that place try to
write about Flesh and Blood characters
and if you must write about abstractions
like truth then try to turn them into
visual characters by making them the
subjects of verbs that tell a story the
next point about brain brain optimized
writing is organized as follows first
the reader's attention will be hooked
with a sudden change of tone second a
three-part framework will be used to
establish the problem and set up the
solution then an example of the problem
will be provided from there an
explanation of the relationship between
the example and the problem will be
provided did I lose you no wonder I was
using the same format that writers have
been using since the Roman Empire and
back then that format actually had a
purpose but why are we still writing
that way today readers find it so boring
and dull how many times have you come
across passages like this chapter 2
discusses the social factors that lead
to declining birth rates the preceding
paragraph demonstrates that economic
conditions play a significant role in
declining birth rates the previous
section analyzed the economic factors
contributing to declining birth rates
this section raises the question of
their impact on labor shortages the
final topic to be discussed is policy
responses these passages all suffer from
meta discourse that's writing about
writing meta discourse is like a street
sign giving GPS coordinates within the
text it's also known in writing as
signposting and it's a hangover from an
old trick in rhetoric tell them what
you're going to tell them tell them and
then tell them what you told them that
rule made a lot of sense back when
public speaking was more dominant than
and writing people giving speeches
needed to figure out a way to keep the
audience's Mind from wandering so they
would repeat points and let people know
explicitly what's coming up and we still
use metad discourse all the time in
regular conversation but in writing this
kind of signposting is totally
unnecessary you don't need to hold your
reader hand and constantly point out
where you're going good writing takes
readers on an easy Journey if the path
to the destination is clearly laid out
then you don't need to pull over over
every 15 minutes to check them out
instead here's how you can manage
expectations in your writing so that
readers can sit back and enjoy the ride
sign posts sparingly as we do in
conversation one way to introduce topics
in conversation is by asking a question
so instead of saying chapter 2 discusses
the social factors that lead to
declining birth rates you could just say
what social factors make birth rates
decline use visual language treat the
content like something that's happening
in the world World rather than just on
the page you could say as we have seen
economic conditions play a significant
role in declining birth rates visual
language like this is great because
seeing implies seers so we're no longer
having to refer to the text
demonstrating this or arguing that in
other words the main characters in the
story are not the units of discourse
it's the writer and the reader who are
taking part in the spectacle together
now in addition to Vision writers and
readers can move together and cooperate
on projects so you can talk about
arriving to or finishing with a topic
now that we have seen the economic
factors contributing to declining birth
rates we arrive at the question of their
impact on labor shortages the final
topic to be discussed is policy
responses let's finish with policy
responses getting rid of meta discourse
is a great way to clarify your writing
but if clear writing is what you want
then it's not enough to simply delete
all the meta discourse you've got to
know how to organize what's left over so
watch this video next because it's going
to show you three tricks for writing
great sentences that will ensure that
your reader has a smooth journey through
your next text so be sure to go check it
out
[Music]